Speaker 1: one of the side stories at CPAC
is that MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell had a complete
and total meltdown in the exhibit hall.
Robert Costa is a reporter for CBS News.
And there's video of pillow flipping out and
calling Robert Costa a traitor.
There were times when if a business leader
behaved this way, their business would be
shut down within a month because everybody
would say, I'm not going to buy from this
guy.
But look at the behavior of pillow.
Check this out.
Unidentified: Should it be over house music
later tonight?
No, you guys just.
You're right, you're right.
Speaker 1: OK, so we actually have a better
angle and audio, so this is from Robert Costa
actually filming it himself and pillows completely
irrational.
He seems totally out of his mind.
And Trump actually during his speech, said
Mike Pillows here.
He's so great.
And the crowd gave him a standing ovation.
This is how the guy was behaving in the hallway.
Speaker 2: Traitor, traitor.
A traitor.
Does it?
Robert Costa is a traitor to
Speaker 1: United, by the way, Kostka?
I love
Speaker 2: that.
Love America.
You know you're a traitor.
This is old news.
You regurgitate.
You care about where you protect the company
called Dominion and you attack a company called
MyPillow.
You're a traitor to our country and your discussed
traitor,
Unidentified: traitor, traitor, traitor, traitor,
Speaker 2: traitor.
You're disgusting.
Disgusting.
Speaker 1: What's funny is Costas really a
pretty uncontroversial reporter.
He's just he's just a reporter.
Speaker 2: Yes, you're one step above Fox.
He doesn't talk at all.
That's what you guys are.
He's asking me about the picture at the White
House a year ago.
Speaker 1: You're disgusted by the way, the
picture at the White House a year ago where
a pillow came out and the zoom in showed that
it said, like state of emergency on his piece
of paper, martial law, something like that.
That's that.
We still haven't really gotten answers to
that.
And I asked Pillow about it during our interview.
And he was he was pretty evasive.
It's hard to find a more deranged guy more
in over his head than Mike Pillow and Trump
actually praised him.
And here's just one more clip this is Phenix
kid reporter asking Pillow for an example
of the election fraud and pillow didn't like
it and walked away.
Here we go.
Speaker 2: So what did you think of President
Trump's speech as one of his best friends
ever?
And why do you think that is?
Well, because he brought up all the election
crimes in the 2020 election crimes.
All the stuff was happening.
We got to keep getting the word out.
And he told the media how rotten they are,
but they never reported anything that was
going to help save our country.
Or what election crimes are discrete election
crimes?
Yes, I'm serious.
Are you serious, really?
No, I'm saying for people who haven't really,
if no deal, no jumpy, go to free speech scam,
then on TV, you can see all the crime right
there over.
And then he walks away.
Speaker 1: Phenix Kid reporter instantly triggering
Mike Pillow there, so it's out of control.
After the break, we'll talk about the event
next door AfPak, the openly white nationalist
competitor to CPAC